Eu acho que estava um bocadinho mais relaxada até vocês saírem daqui.
Acho que estava um bocadinho mais.
Mas agora já fica, já... Nem que não seja a falar comigo, mas já é.
Na família, não é?
Próxima, nos amigos.
E que isto passe depressa.
E que corra tudo bem, que fique bem.
E que o tempo, agora, morte por me acordarem na sala no recobro.
O tempo me custou muito a passar.
Custou mais, até pensava que se tinha esquecido de mim, estou a brincar.
Falou em 12 minutos, não foi?
E foi 12 minutos.
Ah, apareceu assim, tipo, mais, um bocadinho.
Correu tudo bem?
Tudo bem, não tem nada a dizer.
Bem tratada.
As pessoas tratam muito bem os doentes, os pacientes.
Mas tem de ser simplesmente bem tratado.